PROFESSOR: Let's
take a quick look
at the axioms of Zermelo-Frankel
Set Theory With Choice.
So the axioms of ZFC
define the standard theory
of sets, which is now accepted
by most mathematicians
as a reliable and simple basis
for developing and justifying
all of mathematics.
Among the axioms, maybe a
simple want to understand
and really the motivation for
this short video is twofold.
One is practice with
writing predicate formulas,
and the other is to
think a little bit more
about self application.
So one of the basic
axioms of set theory
is called
extensionality, which is
capturing the idea that a set
is determined by its members.
So let's consider the
assertion that two sets x and y
have the same elements,
which we could write
as a predicate formula
in set theory as for all
x, x is a member of y, if and
only if x is a member of z.
Now we could use this is
a definition of equality.
It's what we mean by
y and z are equal.
But we don't really need
to even introduce equality
as a basic part of the
language and add axioms
about how it behaves.
There's one axiom that
covers things adequately,
and that is that if two sets
have the same members, then
they are members
of the same sets.
So if all the members of x
and y are the same, then x
and y are members of exactly
the same thing, which
we could say this
way, for every x,
y is an x, if and
only if z is an x.
So that is one of the basic
axioms of Set Theory, maybe
the starting one.
Another one is the
Power Set axiom,
which simply says that
every set has a power set.
How would you say that in
the language of predicate set
theory?
Well, you'd say
that for every x,
there is a p, which is going to
be the power set effects, such
that for every set s, s is
a subset of x, if and only
if s is a member of p.
Remember, we know how to
express s as a subset of s
in the language of
predicate calculus,
mentioning only membership.
So this is a good axiom
that says, yes, there
is a set p consisting of
precisely the subsets of x.
That set p called
the powers set of x.
When you're trying to deal
with the Russell's paradox
kind of issue, where you
define a set of element
or a collection of
sets that satisfies
some property, the safe
conservative version of saying
that a set of elements that
satisfy some property really
is a set, a collection
of elements that satisfy
some property, really is a
set, the comprehension axiom's
a simple version of an axiom
that allows you to do that.
So basically, it
says that if s is
a set and p of x is an arbitrary
predicate of set theory, which
might in fact be one of
these dangerous things
like x is not a member
of x, nevertheless,
if you look at those
elements in the set
S that satisfy P
of x, that's a set.
In other words, the set of x and
s, such that P of x is a set,
it means that any
definable collection
of elements within a set
also form a proper subset.
And the reason why
this matters is,
remember, if I just talked
about not the set of x
in a particular set
s the satisfied P
of x, if I just talked about
the collection of x's that
satisfied P of x, that's when
I start getting into Russell's
paradox areas, when I
declare that the set of x
such that P of x is a set
for unrestricted P of x.
But all I get to do is put
a bound on the elements
that x ranges over, that x is a
member of some particular set.
Then it's safe to take all of
those x's that satisfy P of x.
Now another particularly
interesting axiom
of ZF which addresses this issue
of self membership and self
reference is that the intuitive
idea that the elements of a set
have to come before
the set itself.
They have to be simpler
than the set itself,
if you think about
sort of building up
a set from successively
simpler elements to more
complicated ones.
In particular, you can't have
a set be a member of itself
because then it's
not being built
from things that are
simpler than it is
or that came before it.
In fact, you can't
even have a set that's
a member of a member of itself.
All of that kind of indirect
membership is forbidden.
Now, how do you say
that is a nice axiom?
Well, there's a very
elegant way to do it,
and that is to say
that all sets are well
founded under membership,
which means that you can't find
an infinite sequence of
sets where each one has
the next one as a member.
Let's give a precise
way to formulate that.
It's also good practice with
the formulas of set theory.
Let me say that x is membership
minimal, epsilon minimal, in y
means that x is a member of
y, but there's no element of x
that's also in y.
In other words, x is built out
of things that are not in y,
but x itself is in y.
So x kind of comes before any
of the other elements in y.
It's built out of non-y stuff.
So to say this with a formula we
could just say that x is in y,
and for every z, if it's
in x, then it's not in y.
So that's the definition of
x is membership minimal in y.
And then the basic axiom of ZF,
called the Foundation Axiom,
simply says that every
nonempty set has a membership
minimal element.
This is actually a
kind of generalization
of the well ordering
principle that
says that every nonempty
set of non-negative integers
has a least element.
This is a direct analogy.
Just as the in
principle for integers
implies that you can't
have an infinite decreasing
sequence of
non-negative integers,
the Foundation Axiom
actually implies
that you can't have an infinite
sequence of sets, each of which
is a member of the previous one.
Here is a formula that's
asserting Foundation.
For every x, if x is not empty,
that implies that there is a y,
such that y is
membership minimal in x.
What is the Foundation
got to do with membership?
Well, the Foundation
Axiom actually
will very quickly let us
conclude that no set is
a member of itself.
How does that work?
Well, suppose that you are
interested in some set,
and you'd like to verify
that the set can't
be a member of itself.
Well, let R be the set
consisting of just this set S
that you're interested in.
R is the singleton S, its
only element in S. Well,
R is not empty.
And by the Foundation Axiom,
it must have a membership
minimal element.
Now suppose that
S isn't S. We're
going to reach a contradiction.
The claim is that R has no
membership minimal element,
and that violates
the Foundation Axiom,
so you can't have S is a member
of S. Why does this follow?
Well, look, R is supposed
to have a membership
minimal element.
Well, R's only got one element.
So if it's got any membership
element, it's got to be S.
But S this can't be
membership minimal
because S is in R,
which means that S
has an element in R in it.
So S is not R minimal.
And the Foundation
Axiom then immediately
implies that you can't have
S be a member of S. S is not
membership minimal in
R. And this argument
extends in a nice way to
member of a member and member
of a member, and we'll throw
a feedback on one question
about that at you shortly.
So looking at the Foundation
Axiom and the conclusion
that no set is a member of
itself, what we can immediately
conclude is that, first of
all, the collection of all sets
can't be a set because if
the collection of all sets
was a set, then it would
be a member of itself,
and that's forbidden
by the S can't
be a member of S consequence
of the Foundation Axiom.
The second thing it tells
us is remember the set W
from Russell's paradox?
W was the collection
of those sets which
are not members of themselves.
Well, now we've just figured
out that this is all sets
because no set is
a member of itself.
So the sets that are not
members of themselves
is everything, and that's
why W is not a set and not
a member of itself,
which explains finally
how the Foundation Axiom
resolves the Russell paradox.